What we've talked about in
recombinant DNA so far is how to get
a piece of DNA from somewhere and
make a whole lot of copies of it.
So, instead of working with DNA
extracted from my cells,
which there's 3 billion different
base pairs of sequence,
we can find a little stretch of DNA.
But simply being able to clone it,
it was a long way from him being
able to get a lot of a fragment of
DNA to be able to figure out what
that sequence is.
That sequence of that gene is
actually from the [zero derma?
gene, the gene that's broken and
the zero derma pigmentosa variant
patience, missing one of these
translesion DNA polymerases that can
copy over a thymine,
thymine, [permadine?],
[dymer?], this induced by UV light.
So the reason they have that
problem with their skin after
sunlight is because they are missing
a polymerase that can't copy over
accurately over this very common
lesion caused by DNA damage.
But how do you get from having a
piece of DNA and having the sequence?
So, the first thing that people
learn to do, and you still do this
all the time in any molecular
biology lab.  We're sort of
switching now in engineering as
you'll see.  You're going to see in
the next things that I'm going to
say, proteins that were,
I talked to you about because of
their biological roles.
DNA polymerase is,
ligases, we learned what they do.
And now you're going to see them
used in manipulative ways.
Restriction enzymes: they have a
biological purpose,
too.  They weren't put on Earth for
me to cut up into fragments and
clone.  They were there to give the
bacteria is some kind of primitive
immune system.
But the first thing that you often
have to do, and you have,
let's say, a plasmid into which
we've inserted a fragment.
And let's say it was the kind of
cloning we described the other day,
where I had cut to the vector with
an ECO-R1 site,
and the other DNA with an ECO-R1
site.  So these,
the junction between the inserted
fragment and the cut vector has
re-created two ECO-R1 sites now.
And if I cut with ECO-R1, I'll just
undo what I did in the cloning,
and we should get the vector DNA and
the insert DNA back again.
So, I can go from this vector to
give us an orientation.
I'm going to imagine that it has
one more restriction site.
This one is called [sal 1?
.  It just recognizes a different
sequence.  So,
if I take the plasmid DNA and cut
with ECO-R1, I just reversing
the cloning.
So I should get is the vector DNA
and the insert that I generated in
the first place.
But I have to detect them somehow.
Unfortunately, they don't just look
in the test tube like that.
So, what people do is they use a
very simple principle.
It's called gel electrophoresis.
And the idea is you just make a gel
of something.  In this particular
case, it's just made of augur,
which is agarose.  These are
polysaccharide products,
often derived from seaweed or
something like that.
They have the property that if you
warm them up, they're liquid,
and that if you let them cool down,
they're a gel.  You've run into
Jell-O which has the property.
That's actually made of a protein
rather than a carbohydrate.
But it's that kind of principle.
So it's very easy to pour something
and that let it solidify.
Now you've got a slab.  And it's
just a network of things that
interact.  And the principle of the
thing is that,
so you have to get the molecules to
move.  Well that's pretty easy with
nucleic acids because
they're charged.
They have all those phosphates.
They've got a lot of negative
charge.  So if you apply an electric
field, they'll move.
And the principle of the thing is
that if you're big,
it's harder to wiggle through this
network than if you are small.
Or you can think of a big, fat
person trying to go through a forest
with a lot of trees,
and a little skinny one.
And if we let them have a race,
eventually the skinny one will
emerge from the forest first.
And so, if we had a set of markers
down on the side where this is big,
and this is small, and we take this
piece of DNA, we're going to get two
fragments.  The bigger one would be
the vector and the smaller one would
be an insert.  So from that,
we could say, oh, if I didn't know
what I started with I could say what
must be at that plasmid?
Is the vector?
And I can run at all by itself and
see it's exactly the same size.
And I got an insert of this
particular size.
And now, can I learn anything more
about that just using restriction
enzymes?  And let's say
I now take the same.
Actually, maybe I'll do it over here.
So let's cut,
this time, with ECO-R1 plus another
restriction enzyme.
They all have these weird names:
[bam H1?], and let's see what
happens.  Well suppose I do that and
I get something like this.
Well it looks like the vector wasn't
cut at all.  That still seems to be
the same, but it looks as though the
insert got cut into two pieces.
Since it was linear, it must have
one site in it.
And so, this molecule that I cloned
could look, be one of
two kinds of ways.
It could be like this.
Let's say this is the insert.
Here's the ECO-R1.  I'll use this
sal 1 to orient us.
So, the bam site could either be
close over here.
Or it could be over on the other
side.  Does that make sense?
The logic is pretty simple.  How
can I tell which of those is correct?
Just doing the kind
of stuff I'm doing.
Beautiful, beautiful.
So if we cut with the sal 1 plus
the bam H1.  In one case,
one would get a fragment like that.
In the other case, get a fragment
like that.
That should feel uneasily familiar
to you.  It should feel just like
what we are doing what we did that
phage cross, and we had some genes
that were lined up.
And we were trying to figure,
was the orientation this way?  Or
was the orientation that?
That was exactly the same principle.
And so this is usually,
in the lab you'd call this
restriction mapping,
or making a restriction map.
And it enabled people to manipulate
fragments of DNA and make inferences
about their orientation and other
features before we can actually even
sequence DNA.
And that's just part of routine sort
of stuff you do a lab.
The equipment is disarmingly simple.
It looks something like that,
usually you're putting some colored
dye so you can see that the things
are moving down the gel.
And the way you visualize the DNA
is you add a molecule.
The name of it doesn't particularly
matter.  It's called ethidium
bromide.  But its property is it
doesn't fluoresce when it's just in
solution.  But it's a flat molecule,
and it can interpolate in between
the base pairs in DNA.
They have all those stacked base
pairs going down a helix.
This molecule's flat, edit likes to
slip inside.  And now it's a much
more hydrophobic environment.
It's hidden from the water, becomes
florescent.  And so,
DNA that's soaked up this dye then
will fluoresce when you put a UV
light on it.  So if I take the gel
out of there after I've run it,
and soak it in this dye and then
shine a little handheld UV light on
it, it would look something like
that if I photographed it.
And so, you would end up with those
patterns that look exactly like that.
Oops, I guess I took the other one
out.  But you can,
of course, depending on how
complicated it is,
you could have a lot of different
fragments.  OK,
so the next big thing that had to
happen in order for us to really
move to where we are in today's
molecular biology was somehow,
DNA had to be sequenced.
And as I say, when I was an
undergrad, or even when I was just
about to start,
when I was a postdoc anyway,
just again it seemed like how would
you ever do it?
Because every nucleotide was joint
by a phosphodiester bond.
The only difference was the base
that was there.
It seemed very, very difficult.
It was hard to imagine you would
ever be able to sort out the
sequence of a billion base pairs.
Of course, you could clone.  Now
you've got maybe a fragment of DNA
that's a couple hundred base pairs
long, and at least the problem
becomes smaller.
Maybe you could work it out.
Now, there were a couple of
different ways of doing it.
One was by Wally Gilbert, who's up
at Harvard who got half the Nobel
Prize for doing this.
The other principle, the other one
that's proved to be most generally
useful is Fred Sanger from England.
And he had Wally shared the Nobel
Prize for discovering sequencing.
And the principal was disarmingly
simple.  I think it's one of these
great ideas do you look back at
afterward and think,
I could have thought of that.
You guys already know everything
you need to invent how to sequence
DNA.  I've told you all
the stuff already.
But nobody's come down to tell me
that you've got it.
And I didn't think of it.
So here is the principal.  What
we've talked about,
if we take a DNA polymerase plus the
four deoxynucleotide triphosphate's,
remember we talked about
deoxyribonucleotide,
the adenosine triphosphate,
and so on.  There's four different
ones.
And we take a primer.
And there's a three prime hydroxyl
right there.  And so this is the
other strand is going the opposite
direction.  If we add that,
I think you all know what's going to
happen.  We're going to get an
extension to the other end.
And what happens every time we add a
nucleotide is that three prime
hydroxyl attacks the phosphate of
the triphosphate.
We lose two of the phosphates.
This is called pyrophosphate, and
we've created a new five to three
prime linkage.
That gives us a new three prime
hydroxyl, and we repeat the process,
right?  That's what we talked about.
So, what would happen,
let's spike in a little,
let me do it.  It's a little deoxy
TTP.  So this is dideoxy.
But what would we mean by that?
Well, if this,
remember where the deoxy came from?
The ribose has at the two prime
position has a hydrogen instead of a
hydroxyl, and at the three prime
position it has a hydroxyl.
If we made a dideoxy, what we do is
we'd make that.  What could
that nucleotide do?
Well, as long as the polymerase
thought it was useful it would use
this end, it would have its
triphosphate up here.
So, somebody else's three prime OH
could come down and form a bond to
here and we'd lose this.
So it could get incorporated.
That chain is finished.  It can't
be elongated anymore.
So, let's think what would happen if
we had, let me stretch this out a
little bit here,
and let's imagine we had a few A's
in the sequence.
So, we are just going to spike it a
bit.  So, most of the things will
not see a dideoxy.
So, this primer will put,
we'll try elongating this.
So when we get to this point,
this point many of them will put it
an ordinary A,
but a few will put it a dideoxy.
And those will finish.  At that
point, they can't go any farther.
The rest of them keep going, [the
various?] nucleotides.
When we get to the next A,
most of them will put them a good T,
but the ones that put in a dideoxy
will stop, and they will generate a
fragment that looks like that.
You get the idea.
Out of this reaction,
we are going to get a set of
fragments.  And each one terminates
where there was an A up there.
Now, in this newer emulation of
this thing, we have a T.
And the trick is to put a dye that
you can attach to this nucleotide,
so it has a particular color.
So, suppose we had something that
was yellow.  Then this particular
set of fragments would be yellow.
And maybe you can begin to see what
would happen now.
If we did the same game three more
times, each time using a different
deoxy, next time maybe
we'll use dideoxy A.
And we'll put a different colored
dye on it.  Then every time,
in this case we come to a T in the
template, it would stop,
and we'd get a little fragment
that's stopped because it
incorporated a dideoxy A,
and those would be, let's say,
green.  So, by the end of this,
we would have all possible fragments
if we mixed them all together and
the last nucleotide on each fragment
would say who it was by its color.
So, if you were to,
then, take this whole mixture of DNA
fragments and you run them down a
gel, in this case it's a difference
of polyacrylamide gel because you
have smaller trying to get things to
go by smaller fragments.
You could sort of see what would
happen.  The big ones would be at
the top.  The small ones would be at
the bottom.  And you'd see each band
would have a different color
depending on the dideoxy that
terminated its chain.
So, if you had a little scanner that
just goes along,
it can read this,
and it will print out something.
And these are always slightly
idealized.  This is a real one.
But this is the sort of stuff you
get back.  If you send a piece of
DNA over to a sequencing center,
they'd send this back as a file or
something.  And you'd sit there.
And it's very good these days.
The technology wasn't as good,
but they can almost always now get
the sequence.  Occasionally,
you'll get something like a run of
G's that gets a little hard,
but what they'll do is they'll sort
of what they call sequencing [bow
strands?].  You can see this way,
but really only looking at the
information of one strand.
So, if we took the other strand.
So if we took the other strand, and
we did the same thing,
but we should get the complementary
piece of information.
So, what this DNA sequencing allows
you to do, then,
is determine the exact sequence of
nucleotides in some kind of piece.
And much of the art from the rest of
it then comes,
how do you assemble all of those
things together?
In the case of a bacteria or
something, it wasn't so bad because
its DNA was small enough.
You could cut it into a bunch of
sort of big fragments,
and then take each one of those,
and then the sorting problem was
relatively simple.
In the case of something like
humans, it was really complicated
because there were
so much more DNA.
And the other thing is higher
organisms such as yourselves have a
lot of repeated DNA.
It's just the same sequence,
and sometimes there's quite a bit of
it, a bunch of repeats.
And so, if you see that at the end
of your thing,
you don't really quite know where
you are in the genome.
So a lot of other tricks had to be
brought into play,
including knowledge of the human
genetic map.  And so you could get
yourself anchored at various places
because you do on this particular
piece of DNA, because it was
associated with some gene,
had to be here on the chromosome.
And therefore,
things at least decide beside it
were there on the chromosome.
And there were a whole lot of
tricks to putting it together.
But the very basic principle of how
we sequence DNA has at its heart the
same process that I was talking to
you about as when we were doing DNA
replication, except in this case
it's just used in a very clever way.
And that was an amazing idea.
It got a Nobel Prize,
and you've been sitting here for the
last month with all the knowledge to
do it.  You keep emphasizing that
you've got to have that three prime
hydroxyl.  But some of the great
ideas often when you look back you
could see it was the hurdle was kind
of small.  And they didn't even have
to do this with dyes at the
beginning.  In fact,
that was a later innovation.
The key thing was just the
dideoxies stopping in each place.
I was lucky enough to live through
some of this, the development of
this technology.
OK, so I've got one more really big
thing to tell you,
which again was extraordinarily
clever, but extraordinarily simple
once you heard about it.
And it was one more technological
advance.  It wasn't a big insight
into biology in and of itself,
but it was a technology that opened
up just incredible experimental
possibilities.
And it's something known as the
polymerase chain reaction.
And this allows,
in principle, someone like me to go
and to grab a single cell from you,
take it to DNA, and get a copy of
any gene I want from your genome.
And I can look and see whether you
have any mutations in that genome,
or whether there are different
polymorphic alleles in the
population, in which one you've got
from your mom,
or which one you got from your dad.
So, you take from a single DNA
molecule, I can make as much as I
want.  And this is just like DNA
sequencing.  You guys already know
everything you need to know to
invent this technique as well.
It has very much that same property.
It's another one of these very
brilliant insights that you just had
to put things in the right place.
So let me explain the principle.
So, suppose that I would like to
know there's a gene that I know
there's a family history of
something, and I would like to know,
but I happen to get the allele that
carries that?  Or did I get the one
that didn't?  So,
in principle what I would like to do
is to get a hold of the piece of DNA
for that gene from my own cells.
But all I've started with is my
entire DNA.
Well, I could clone it.
I could make a recombinant library.
I could do everything else.  But
there's this other simple way.
And one way this involves, what it
involves taking,
is since I know the sequence of the
genome now, I know that almost
everything is going to the same.
There will be little differences
between individuals.
I'll make a little primer that
corresponds to the sequence that one
end of the gene,
and another primer that corresponds
to the DNA at the other end of the
gene, or whatever fragment
I want to use.
And that's all I have to do in terms
of getting anything made.
Now the rest, we are just going to
play games with DNA,
with DNA polymerase, and nucleoside
triphosphates,
just all the stuff I dragged you
through talking about DNA
replication.  So here's the idea.
So here's my DNA, let's say, or
part of it.
If I could actually see the sequence,
I would know, let's say,
the gene I'm interested in is in
here.  So, what I would do is make a
little primer.
It just has to be enough to confer
specificity for something with
humans.  If I make something
probably 30 nucleotides long,
that's enough.  It'll only bind one
place in the DNA.
And I make one, let's say,
for the opposite strand over here.
So remember, this is five prime,
three prime, five prime to three
prime.  So the principles will heat
to 95∞C, and will denature the DNA.
And we'll add an excess of the two
primers.
And let's say we'll cool to 55∞C,
or something.  And we'll cool it
down enough so that we can get the
primers on.  But we are not going to
go all the way and let all the
strands find their way back.
And we'll add a DNA polymerase plus
four deoxy nucleoside
triphosphates.
Well, what will happen?
Well, here's one of the strands.
And we'll prime it here, let's say.
So, it will copy down here and go
as far as it can go.
And the other one starts here.
And it's going to go down all that
way.  Let's just repeat the whole
process now, OK?
What'll happen?  Now when we pull
them apart, we ought to have four
strands.  We'll have the original
ones here, and when I repeat the
process, the same thing's
going to happen again.
This one will go here,
and it will copy out.  This one will
go here.  It will copy out.
But what about this guy?  So,
this one becomes this one here.
So the primer that it does will
copy it, and it can't
go any further.
I just generated a piece that's
exactly what I wanted.
And the same deal here: as long as
I don't get lost,
which what did I do?
So, we've got this guy here.
So, it starts there.  So this one
becomes this one,
and we'll prime it here.
It'll go along and it will stop.
So there's the complementary strand
to the one here.
And I think this is sort of like
doing a math problem.
You can't just look at it and say,
we'll maybe you will get it.  But
there's nothing like sitting down
with a pencil and paper,
and take yourself through several
cycles.  What you will believe is
how quickly you get to get being
nothing but, almost nothing,
but the sequence that you are trying
to amplify.
And so, this again has an
astonishing effect.
This is why you hear about DNA
testing all the time in forensics,
because you can take a tiny bit of
DNA from saliva,
or semen, or blood,
or whatever they might find on a
crime scene, and then they can
amplify little pieces
and they compare.
And there's a trick they use in
forensics, and that is that there
are sequences within the human
genome where the little variable
repeats like GT,
GT, GT, GT, GT, GT,
and I might have 14 of them in one
of my chromosomes.
The one I got from my mom might
have 40.  You might have 24 and
something else,
and so on.  If you were to do PCR
around a little region that was
known to be variable,
if you had 14 repeats you'd get a
shorter fragment.
And if you had 40 repeats,
you get a longer fragment.  So,
I'll come back to that in a sec.
So, if you were to, for example,
take something with a long [repeat
and a?] short peak into this kind of
thing.  We get two fragments,
say, one from the paternal.  And if
you do this with several such sites
around the genome,
pretty soon you run into situations
where the odds of a particular
combination of a long one at the
site, a short one at the site,
and so on, becomes statistically
improbable that it's anyone
other than yourself.
So on a crime scene,
if they did this, they,
for example, might have three
individuals that they were thinking
was possible.  And they'd generate
patterns like this,
say, using three different loci like
this, and then have the
forensic sample.
And it was pretty evident who didn't
do it, and who at least remains a
suspect.  This probably would
improve it.  The very last thing,
just to close us off, is when people
develop this PCR technique,
you had to sit there with your
pipette because every time you
raised it to 90∞ to denature the DNA
you killed your enzyme.
So, you cool it down to 55,
escort it in a new DNA polymerase.
And then someone finally said,
another brilliant idea,
what if I had a thermoresistant
polymerase?  Where would
I find those?
Well, Penny was talking to you about
those events where it's really,
really hot, and those black smokers
and everything,
so maybe you got a bacterium from
their.  It would have a temperature
resistant polymerase.
So here you are from the New
England [Biocatalog?
, [vent exominus?] DNA polymerase,
deep vent DNA polymerase.  People
went to grab those bacteria from
there, grabbed the DNA polymerase
gene.  And now,
the DNA polymerase just sits there.
It just laughs and you bring it up
to 90∞.
And when you cool it back down and
give it a substrate again,
it will do its thing.  And so,
this whole thing can be done
automatic and you don't have to sit
there and pipette something in at
the end of every run,
another little cute sort of
engineering trick that combined
ecology together with biology.
OK, see you on Friday.